Весільна розпорядниця і майбутнє подружжя - в весільному номері.
До свята лишаються лічені дні.
Ця пара, як і багато хто в Німеччині, мріє про розкішне весілля в замку.
Усе має бути ідеально. На святкування молодята
планують витратити 12 тисяч євро.
- Тому що весілля має бути тільки раз у житті.
- Буде!
- Так, буде саме так. Тому ми сказали собі:
витратимо на нього трішки більше.
Це має бути щось особливе. Ми хочемо надовго
запам’ятати цей день, тому вирішили, що
хороші спогади вартують того, аби вкласти трохи більше.
Це має бути щось незабутнє. Буде і феєрверк,
і гра в гольф, і, ясна річ, музиканти.
- Усе набуває дедалі божевільніших обертів.
Люди намагаються спланувати цей день так, щоб
увесь час щось відбувалося:
запрошують комедійних офіціантів, які мають
розважати гостей, художників, які малюють на них карикатури.
А ще плавають на човнах та водних лижах.
Буквально торік у нас гості плавали на водних лижах.
Тобто роблять усе, щоб було весело.
Такому весільному божевіллю неабияк сприяють соціальні мережі - Facebook або Instagram,
адже молодята прагнуть бути красивішими,
кращими за інших.
- Соціальні медіа, які ми сьогодні маємо, і це треба визнати,
подають приклад іншим. І ніхто не хоче пасти задніх.
Якщо порівнювати витрати на весілля з залученням професіоналів
у Німеччині з іншими країнами, то ФРН тримається "золотої середини".
У Німеччині витрачають у середньому 15 тисяч євро,
тоді як серед лідерів - США.
Там одруження влітає у майже 30 тисяч євро, а також Китай.
- На російських весіллях заведено, що обов’язково
має бути ведучий, який увесь час розважає гостей.
А ще багато випивки, і молодята часто сидять окремо за столом.
Це суттєво відрізняється від нашого святкування.
Турецькі весілля так само часто дуже великі.
Їжі на них не приділяють багато уваги, часто її подають дуже пізно.
Здебільшого святкування влаштовують у спортзалах.
Весілля, народження дитини - кожна нова фаза стає подією в житті,
яку неодмінно слід пишно відсвяткувати.
Навіть розлучення, якого ніхто з щойно одружених, звісно, не хоче.